by and large both the christian and
muslim traditions they view politics and
political players with a certain amount
of skepticism and disdain and
historically speaking the number of
individuals who have been both saintly
and political players at the same time
can probably be counted on the fingers
of one hand and this is true
historically and scripturally as well
there are scriptural references in the
Bible and in the the prophetic sayings
that really speak against getting too
much involved in politics a good
religious person always has to place God
first and a good political there will
always place country first so the
question that I have really is a
personal question do you not think that
if one person wishes to excel in one of
the two faiths or politics Excel and not
just necessarily be a member because you
have Muslim politicians and Christian
politicians but to truly excel in one of
the two is that not done at the expense
of the other well that is a very good
question but I think no it's not first
of all I think you know for people of
religious faith to disdain politics it
is very often and I'm going to be quite
some rough here on the religious side of
the equation it's very often because
they can be permitted never to take a
difficult decision right they they can
be permitted to simply sail above the
practical things in life that have to be
sorted out right and actually the best
religious people in my view have a
respect for politics because they do
actually understand that it's about
difficult social economic you know
broadly appealing political questions
and also instantly there are religious
leaders not not least the prophet who
were in fact political leaders and who
had to take very difficult political
decisions and decisions in relation to
war and peace to
so I would actually say on the contrary
this is my second point that if you are
in in public life you know yes there
will be situations of compromise and
expediency but my point is that i think
what faith helps and stop it again let
me emphasize not the only route to it
that it is a major route to helps draw a
limit to that at some point so that you
might I mean let's take an issue to do
which is a a difficult issue and there's
been a major issue here and elsewhere
let's say the issue of torture right
let's say you think somebody has got
information you think you need that
information in order to save other lives
you know this is difficult the
certificate units not easy these
decisions but I think at some point you
say no that can't that's just not it's
not possible it's that is fundamentally
antithetical to the values we believe in
ah as I say personally I Drive those
values through faith but you don't have
to drive them through faith but I think
it helps in that way so I would say
they're actually the best religious
leaders understand the world of politics
and it is at least helpful if the world
of politics understand the issues to do
with with faith and I think there should
not be disdain on either side but it's a
healthy dialogue to have between your
conscience and your constituency I think
that that I would I think that's another
thing I'd say that it's actually healthy
that that process goes on in the
decision-makers mind you know there are
some people who the process now may not
go on at all you know it's going to do
it's about interest here's my interest
and that's what I do I think it is at
least healthy that in the
decision-makers mind that processes is
engaged with
you